another classic puzzle if it's all right
this time I want your gut reaction and I
encourage viewers to note their gut
reaction before you Ponder further it's
one of those classic ones where you
should get gut reaction park it and then
analyze whether it has any sense to it
and this time I'm going to ask you a
probability question I'd like you to
answer this question on the scale of
impossible I.E probability zero up to
certain and I don't really care about a
number if you can give me a number I'll
be impressed the 50 50 is there let's
call this very unlikely unlikely likely
very likely I think you get the idea so
that's your scale to use and here comes
the question what are the chances
that there are two people in London
with the same number of hairs on their
head
remember you don't need to give me a
number I want somewhere on this scale
very close to zero okay so I'm gonna put
a Brady
BH like down here is that is that fair
yeah do you want to be closer to zero
than that
no I I'd maybe go even a shade closer
but that'll do for now we're talking
ballparks only but the idea of actually
giving me a percentage answer seems
nonsense as well I think so my claim is
which I will try and answer in the
remainder of the video is that I know
exactly where on the scale the answer is
and I know it's a full Precision full
Precision like I can nail the absolute
full decimal expansion if you wanted me
to
and I'm just checking the viewers who've
got your gut reactions you may disagree
with Brady you may agree uh maybe you
disagree by like a fraction of percent
who knows
so uh the reason I'm asking this
question is that there's a little bit of
background I want to explain in the UK
there's a qualification you can take
post 16
if you're not doing an a11 Mass you can
do something called core maths now it's
a relatively recent thing it's the
matter of everyday life and it's really
useful for students to take who are not
going to do an a level in maths but
still want to keep some basic numeracy
understand headlines it sounds like a
sales pitch a little bit because I think
more people should do it but the point
is part of that course is estimation
skills like you get examined how well
you can estimate things and there's
these classic types of questions called
Fermi questions or Fermi estimations
where the story is that Enrico Fermi the
physicist estimated this size of an
atomic blast he didn't have any other
way of measuring it so he dropped a
piece of paper noticed how far the blast
wind blew it and got the size of the
blast within a factor of two detail
didn't matter but the size estimate was
a really useful skill and actually
knowing roughly how many things occur
maybe I don't know like the number of
people in London or maybe the hairs on
your head those questions are tied up
with this so we're going to use a bit
Fermi estimation to solve this once and
for all it wasn't a trick question
you're not counting people with zero
hairs on their head eh well if we did
what's your answer yeah well then then
it's one because there are two people
with zero but I'm not counting that
Brady inexplicably that's at the other
end of the scale from your guess but
let's say to be fair to you that we are
not counting that maybe we should
rephrase the question most people are
shouting at the screen probably think
what about bald people so if we said
what are the chances of two hairy people
with whatever that means having the same
number of hair follicles on their head
whatever we could have hair follicles
whatever we're going to do some
estimation in typical core maths style
how many hairs are on our heads like are
we talking
10 million are we talking 10 I'm
regretting my decision now there aren't
that many hairs on her head well so I
had a thought about how to give people
advice estimating stuff is hard which is
incidentally why they use these sort of
questions as interview questions quite
often like how many tennis balls can you
fit on a jumbo jet I've heard there's a
Google interview question no one cares
about the answer they care about how you
think about it so
maybe you come up with your own ways of
thinking about hairs on your head I had
an idea which is
I had a 30 centimeter ruler in my drawer
a nice bendy one and I can sort of like
well it's it's roughly my hair is
roughly like 30 centimeters by 30
centimeters I mean I know my hair is a
source of contention among a number of
our viewers there's been incidences on
camera where I had questionable hair and
possibly still do but we're leaving that
aside you think I haven't just put them
on screen that's cute
I talked myself into that didn't I new
number four video new haircut that's my
motto
and I think actually if you drill down
the size of my head is kind of within
grasp of centimeters and if you think
about like a one centimeter squared
patch no close-ups right I think we can
get an order of magnitude so I think
there's probably more than 10 hairs in a
centimeter squared like it like feels
like sparse probably not as many as a
thousand so let's pick a hundred
I'm going to start writing some stuff
down 100 hairs per centimeter squared
and then roughly let's get the size of
my head so when I've already waved the
rule around this 30 centimeters by 30
centimeters approximately 900
centimeters squared times a hundred
ninety
thousand hairs how do you feel about
that loads of people in London have the
same number of hairs on their head you
wanted to change your answer I'm glad we
are already acknowledging that there is
doubt creeping into your earlier gut
reaction so let's just settle it once
and for all uh I don't even trust my
estimation but if we went to let's call
it a hundred thousand I don't think many
people are going to be in order of
magnitude out from that incidentally I
did do some research on this and
apparently redhead people have uh fewer
hairs
quality not quantity apparently is the
name but roughly people are estimating
between fifty thousand hundred fifty
thousand so I'm really glad our estimate
is pretty good
[Music]
I was doing London Brady
this is like 12 million or 8 million and
anyone who was shouting the screen
earlier when I asked the question would
be like it depends what you define as
London right greater London the city of
London however you really do it I think
we're in millions agreed yeah like even
if you go small and let's say greater
London I reckon about 8 million
but again I don't actually care because
I'm just going to say 8 million you will
see that the actual detail doesn't
really matter now you've already
upgraded your estimate but let's think
about why I'm going to do what they call
in the trade a piece of Common Sense
uh which is the name for a mathematical
theorem which everyone thinks is really
profound and everyone else is like well
that's just obvious but this is called
the pigeonhole principle and if you have
heard of it uh well done you might think
it's common sense if you haven't heard
of it it's time you heard of it so if
there are nine pigeon holes in this
little grid here and I had eight pigeons
they could arrange themselves all
through and there'd be a gap they've got
one pigeonhole each they could arrange
themselves to double up there's no rules
against it if they're particularly cozy
but they don't have to my point is if I
have nine pigeons they could have a
pigeonhole each
they might double up but they don't have
to whereas if I have 10 pigeons two
pigeons are sharing
at least
this is known as common sense to most
people and other people call it the
pigeonhole principle and it's a
surprisingly profound useful result uh
in very different situations if you've
got more things than options
then the people choosing options are
going to double up and I think by the
velocity of your nodding you have seen
how this might apply let's imagine all
the people in London are choosing an
amount of pairs even if they're making
up a number right they just I have
963 hairs and I have 900 000 whatever
they want to be unique they're trying to
be but if eight million people try it
and there's only roughly a hundred
thousand or even two hundred thousand or
even 300 000 options
two of them are going to duplicate
there's nothing we can do about it I'm
sorry to break it to you not only we're
not down here
we are precisely
there
it's 100 and I said I'd do the full
decimal expansion if you want it but it
gets pretty dull pretty quickly so I
like this question because it feels like
our gut reaction goes wrong quickly and
I think it's because we're not very good
at estimating without training
incidentally why Core math is a good
thing to study and it's nice to actually
do an exam where you're rewarded in this
Common Sense way of thinking I studied
maths Ben and I got it wrong I think I
think mathematicians particularly you've
done your share of mass maybe more than
the majority of people in the world are
actually less good at the basic Common
Sense estimating than other people and
people who have to do a lot of this
every day are better at it it just takes
practice and actually studying maths
doesn't involve lots of it which is why
there's an interesting qualification to
talk about
and a good skill to have whatever
qualifications you study the art of
estimation is important and in this case
what's nice is the probability question
not only has a definitive answer all you
need is rough ballpark estimates to nail
it down completely it turns out that the
pigeonhole principle has lots of
important applications if you want to
look at the possibility of things
duplicating if you make up a random
password with a certain key space and
someone else makes it like what are the
chances of duplication occurring
suddenly you realize it's the same sort
of question
and that's important and there are links
to another cliche problem called the
birthday Paradox like what are the
chances two people share a birthday it's
not quite the same but if you have
enough people in that question if you
have 366 people in a room you guarantee
that two of them share a birthday same
idea pigeonhole principle means at least
one is going to double up that's it
that's the hairy problem for you and I
think it's a good advert for estimating
skills and this qualification called
core maths
so continuing the theme of probability
have a look at this it's a new
subscription box from our episode
sponsor mail science in the past I've
shown you some of their cool chemistry
sets but they're also getting into
mathematics and this one has me
intrigued how to never lose
as always everything your needs in the
Box it's a well-explained really
Hands-On I'm making my very own bean
machine here
and have a look at this
lovely and some very nice normal
distributions
where was this when I was a kid I guess
it doesn't matter I can play with it now
that I'm a slightly bigger kid this
snazzy machine comes with handy lessons
other probability games it's really
interactive which is always the best way
to learn and have some fun along the way
you can get 50 off your first purchase
with Mel science by the way check out
the link and details in the video
description or you can just go to
melscience.com have a look see
everything it's a great website
thank you
look at that I could watch that all day
ready
what are the chances of 2 2 people in
London having exactly the same number of
hairs on their head a hundred percent
because of the pigeonhole principle well
this video is really short
there we go